- Good evening, everyone.
And welcome to the
Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences Governors Awards.
Now there's nothing that can take away
from the splashiness
and the enormous significance
of Sunday's 94th Oscars.
But for those of us who've been fortunate
to attend this event,
it's perhaps even closer to our hearts.
It's more intimate, it's
private, not televised.
It involves a cocktail
hour and a free meal.
And, most important, it
represents a generosity of spirit
that's not always in
the Hollywood spotlight.
This night exists because the
Academy's Board of Governors
has taken a moment to step back
from the focus on this
year's singular achievements,
which are astounding and many,
to honor four individuals
we love and adore.
Not only for their
specific accomplishments,
but for their creative careers
and influential lives well lived.
These four gorgeous humans
have each gone above and beyond
having a unique and an
indelible mark to leave.
And we are all the lucky
beneficiaries of their talent,
their insight, and their legacy.
Over the years, we've come to trust them
for their integrity and
their creative bravery.
We've been eager to hear
more and more from them.
And we're grateful for the love affair
that we, and audiences everywhere,
have had with each of them for years.
Now here's a little inside baseball story.
Each year, the Academy's governors
gather for a board meeting
where they suggest recipients
for an honorary award.
It's normally a meeting
full of lengthy speeches
and presentations,
analysis and debate,
and multiple rounds of voting,
which go on for hours and hours,
ending with a picked over fruit platter
and a lot of doodling on legal pads.
But this year, lightning quick.
Fervent advocacy, giddy enthusiasm,
and rapid-fire consensus.
Sam Jackson, hell yeah.
(audience cheering)
Elaine May, genius.
Yes, please!
Liv Ullmann, a goddess
of acting and directing.
(audience cheering)
Bam!
And humanitarian Danny Glover, God bless.
Done!
(audience cheering)
If only all our board
meetings were that brief
and that harmonious.
So we can thank those
extraordinary men and women,
representing the Academy's 17 branches,
for their year-round, tireless work
and their great taste in honorees.
Will our esteemed governors please rise?
(audience clapping)
Okay, board meeting adjourned.
(audience laughing)
I'd also like to take
a moment to thank Rolex
for its generous support of this evening,
and of the Academy, and
the museum year round.
Thank you, Rolex.
And now, here's a line I
couldn't ever say often enough,
ladies and gentlemen, Bill Murray.
(audience clapping)